New Zealand Prime Minister
Jacinda Ardern is being lauded
for a mic drop
moment during a press conference
Ardern and her Finnish counterpa
they met in Auckland
to discuss trade relations
and support for Ukraine.
But one reporter's question anno
A lot of people will be wonderin
are you to be meeting
just because you know
you're similar in age and got a
you know, common stuff.
The, you know,
when you got into politics and s
What can Kiwis
actually expect to see more deal
between our two countries down t
Because my first question is
I wonder whether or not anyone e
Barack Obama and John Key
if they met
because they were of similar age
We, of course, have a higher pro
of men in politics it's reality
because two women meet.
It's not simply because of their
Joining us now is
CNN political commentator S.E. C
One of the best parts
was the body language
where she listens to the questio
with her head like, hmm.
And then she tells her head back
So. Right. Okay.
But let me let me just do someth
Let me play
devil's advocate, S.E.,
because you know, just for fun.
So I think what the reporter
in artfully in artfully was tryi
was you guys,
you know,
New Zealand
and Finland
are not known as trade partners.
So are you guys hatching out a d
or are you just meeting
because you have a lot
personally in common but
it's doing the devil's advocate,
like devil's advocate
You you and I are talking
because we have a lot of stuff i
too, right?
No, I listen,
I am offended by that question
as a woman.
But more as a journalist.
Like that's your question.
What a waste
of an opportunity
to two prime ministers in front
And you're asking about their
stuff in common and stuff.
So I think that was that was bad
But listen,
this is why representation matte
because if you're not,
you know, matters in politics.
It matters also in boardrooms
and in popular culture,
because if you're not seeing tha
you ask stupid questions
like that, stupid questions like
come out of your mouth
because it is novel
to see
two heads of state in the same r
And so,
you know,
yes, it's
it's important
that we elect
more women into politics
and also everywhere else.
Well, representation
and seeing that more and more ma
so that, you know, to ask for qu
not just about their stuff
and comment and stuff, you know,
the question is sexist,
but that's not primarily what I
I didn't hear that first. You he
I thought it was dismissive
because of their
their ages was like, you two wer
Are you just getting together to
You're not really handling
anything like your heads of gove
or anything.
But I thought it was dismissive
because of their age first. Agei
I mean, that happens, too.
And it's part and parcel.
The fact that they are both two
attractive women,
I'm sure was novel to this perso
So I think, yeah,
there was a lot of condescension
I think ignorance
and dumbing down in
in one question,
and I think you're right
to see that as part of it.
But man,
what an opportunity to have aske
these two
women, impressive women
who know a lot about their count
Obviously
some like stuff about their coun
and not just imagine that they'r
to, like, braid each other's hai
and have a pillow fight
because they're two women
of the same age and stuff